bonjour flora augustine etcheverry j'ai
43 ans je suis originaire de saint louis
je suis enquêtrice si je travaille donc
pour l'insee et je suis adjointe à la
mairie de saint-louis donc sur
l'insertion professionnelle la formation
l'économie sociale et solidaire
dans mon canton donc saint-louis canton
15 on dit saint louis ville de passion
c'est un canton
effectivement avec plein de forces vives
beaucoup de potentialités et mais c'est
vrai que c'est un lui c'est aussi l'une
des villes les plus pauvres de france
donc sur lesquels il faut des outils il
faut des moyens pour pouvoir
accompagner la population le mieux
possible et développé en fait les
solidarités je suis plus confiance que
jamais pour saint-louis parce que la
population de saint-louis a osé choisir
le changement à travers le choix d'une
nouvelle mandature de nouveaux
conseillers départementaux donc saint
louis est une ville en pleine mutation
saint louis est une ville en pleine
transformation qui probablement va
s'épanouir pleinement ce canton est cher
à mes yeux parce que pas j'ai grandi
déjà parce que je suis convaincu que des
potentialités sans lui c'est une des
villes qui a eu
les premières la première usine qui a eu
la plus grande église qui acquit à des
eaux qui sont plaints de plein de
richesses et plein de potentialités donc
l'envi de pouvoir faire en sorte que
saint-louis puisse trouver son
rayonnement
alors mes actions prioritaires au sein
du département sera le prolongement
d'action que j'ai commencé en mairie
parce que on a voulu être dans la
proximité est au plus près des besoins
de la population
donc la première action c'est de pouvoir
lutter contre la pauvreté donc pour ça
on a besoin d'outils on a besoin de
moyens de moyens financiers de moyen
humain donc le département c'est le chef
de file du social et c'est celui qui
peut le mieux accompagner chaque canton
donc avec tous les différents
conseillers départementaux
l'idée c'est de pouvoir co construire
ensemble et amener les réponses au plus
près des besoins de la population donc
l'une des priorités pour moi dans mon
champ d'intervention c'est la prévention
et la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales parce que c'est un fléau
qui prend beaucoup de place en fait à la
réunion et notamment pendant un
confinement on a vu que ces violences
intrafamiliales exploser donc prévenir
pouvoir protéger les familles pouvoir
mettre en place en fait les dispositifs
qui sont au plus près de leurs besoins
et puis mettre toutes les forces vives
en actions pour pouvoir lutter contre
cette problématique et accompagner les
personnes
de manière générale la collectivité
départementale peut aider la population
réunionnaise déjà depuis la petite
enfance jusqu'au dernier souffle donc on
a le volet
d'accompagnement à la petite enfance on
a le volet d'accompagnement pour les
collégiens donc on a un volet
d'accompagnement pour nos jeunes pour
l'insertion l'insertion des personnes
qui sont au rsa on a le volet
d'accompagnement pour les personnes qui
sont handicapés porteuses de handicap on
a le volet d'accompagnement pour les
personnes âgées donc vraiment le champ
de travail est immense dans ce noble
idée au département c'est de pouvoir
renforcer les solidarités et puis
permettent que le département de la
réunion puisse pleinement rayonner parce
que véritablement on aime nos cantons
mais on aime aussi notre département